but first we gotta talk about this big
breaking news check out the story we got
from yahoo finance
all of jbs's u.s beef plants were forced
shut by cyber attack let's go for the
quick
quick quick bit here they say a cyber
attack on jbs sa the largest meat
producer globally
forced the shutdown of all its u.s beef
plants
wiping out output from facilities that
supply almost a quarter of america's
supplies
of america's beef when they say supplies
all the companies fed beef and regional
beef plants were forced to shutter
and all other jbs meatpacking facilities
in the country experienced some level of
disruptions
to operations now this means pork as
well according to an official
with the united food and commercial
workers international union
jbs did not immediately respond to
requests for comment i also want to
point out
you know most people don't know this
this you know there's a [ __ ] there's a
chicken shortage
did you hear that so now there's a
double shortage of like just all types
of meat
i think there's i mean there's
ridiculous shortages chlorine shortages
computer chips
gpus obvious for obvious reasons there's
uh shortages
of cars there's shortages of chicken
and what else is what is this it's a
bunch of weird stuff that's like you
can't get
but this this is important because
there's a shortage of chicken
and the first the first hint of chicken
shortage
the media went oh it's because of
popeyes you know they made the chicken
sandwich and now everybody's buying it
so there's none left
you know seriously that's what they said
and i was like that's not true
that no one's buying that much chicken
from popeyes
but they're like but it's the chicken
war kfc's got a chicken sandwich and i'm
like but all they sell is chicken
but popeyes i'm like it's popeye's
chicken it's all they sell and they're
like
well burger king burger king's always
had a chicken sandwich no one is going
as fast with restaurants and being like
give me 10 chicken sandwiches
so i thought that whole thing was weird
then i covered this a few weeks ago
when you look at local news what do they
say chicken shortage chicken shortage
chicken shortage restaurants can't get
cooking oil
restaurants are charging more prices
higher prices and i'm like why isn't
this at like the national level why does
anybody know about this
how come it's only the small towns that
are saying hey you can't get chicken
so something weird is happening i wonder
if
it's worse than they actually say it is
because
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna you know get
conspiratorial anything on this one
but there's a cyber attack on colonial
pipeline which shuts
down the biggest oil pipeline in the
country and just before that happened
some people were saying there's like a
massive leak
of oil some people have said if they
paid the ransom to the hackers within
three hours of the hack
why did they shut the pipeline down why
did dhs come out and say there was no
shortage
when like 87 percent or 83 of gas
stations in dc had no gas
they blamed it all on people panic
buying which some people did
but i'm like i don't know man it's is it
possible the media is just lying to us
that is totally possible yeah how about
that you
wouldn't say yeah right so now we're
we're we're here the white house is
saying this the white house is worried
there could be a major meat shortage
soon
soon huh no but this is crazy because
there's already a shortage on beef
it's it's it's it's not even this is
crazy to me that they're saying this
and i wonder why is this happening after
the shortage already hit
so i posted this thing on instagram i
don't know if you saw it but
there's a barbecue shop not too far away
and like two weeks ago they put up a
sign saying due to the increased price
of beef we can't sell it anymore
because the price per beef doubled and
they said it was because like gas has
gotten so high it's impossible to get
beef
so i'm like we went we have a bunch of
farms around here
and so when we went out to try and find
farm meat the shops
all the farmers were like yeah we're
struggling to get beef like the the
regulators are not letting us
you know harvest meat or whatever it's
being restricted
so i'm like it's kind of weird man the
word they phrased it a major meat
shortage makes me think maybe we're
about to see something we've never seen
before
at least in this generation
with the other shortages you were
talking about is there like reasoning
behind that i think you said
the chips make sense i've been paying
attention to that but i think you said
chlorine
is it because like production was
stymied in 2020 and like now we're
seeing the
net results of that or is there like a
different reasoning per one
i kind of think uh well what's the best
way to describe it
um the system broke
and the the the the establishment is
desperately trying to bail water
but what they're doing is making it
worse right so like they shut
the economy gets shut down by all these
different governors with with the
coveted lockdowns
that is like a freight train going full
speed just stopping
dead in its tracks what happens will all
the carts derail and fly off the tracks
it doesn't just stop
you can't start that train back up so
people don't realize when we're seeing
this
this stuff have you seen these fast food
restaurants like mcdonald's offering a
thousand dollar sign on bonus
yeah that's crazy right nobody wants to
do the job
people see that stuff and they're like
oh isn't it crazy that you know
mcdonald's is offering all that money
and then what you hear from a lot of
these like younger leftist types is
maybe if they paid a living wage people
would want the job
what they don't realize is biden is
giving everybody 300 bucks
per week bonus not to work so people
don't want to work but what they
what they aren't seeing is so they're
like so pay more money okay well you
can't just pay more money they're trying
what what el what else it is you can see
fast food restaurants you can see people
aren't going to mcdonald you like aren't
working at mcdonald's what you can't see
is they're not at steel mills either
they're you you can't see the farms
where people aren't picking the crops
you can't see the people who work the
beef not there either
so it's not just mcdonald's it's across
the board people aren't taking jobs
anywhere
they got a bunch of money and they don't
care so this is crazy like so it's it's
a weird thing that's happening
at the same time we get this the media
telling everybody to eat cicadas
uh don't don't don't eat have you seen
these stories don't eat don't eat i just
don't want
[Laughter]
well you shouldn't they're parasite uh
they could have parasites
they're nasty have you heard them scream
oh god no
have you heard you haven't not not up
close what does it sound like
yeah that's all at the same time but
it's their wings they're not really
screaming
when you when you when you find one and
you pick it up it flattens its wings and
you hear you hear it go whoa
it's like really freaky oh that's the
vibration from the wings fluttering yeah
that's why i grabbed them by the way
super super crazy creepy noise man
anyway the media has been pumping out
articles like crazy telling everybody go
eat these bugs
and now we got one from the atlantic
that's kind of honest about they say
unfortunately some cicadas taste like
nature's gushers
if you must eat them go for air fried
dude they're gross
we made um mid cricket bread
yeah and it's it's like different it was
under what did you think
i see yeah underwhelming underworld not
great not
not horrible yeah i wouldn't call it bad
i would just say like you need it for a
specific kind of food
like i think it would work with a
meatloaf yes savory for sure
mommy i wonder we didn't use it like
four and a half cups of
the cricket flour we just had like one
cup of cricket flour like three and a
half cups of white
wheat flour but it was definitely
noticeable that it's something going on
you got it you got to
you got to get ready for the better so
good for you too it is it's got like
twice the b vitamins and protein of
beef so you got to eat the bugs man
that's the future well going back to
supply issues cicadas only come up like
what once every like 13 years or
something isn't that
there are cicadas year-round but the big
surges
are every year yeah there's cases every
year but they're you barely see them
you'll you'll hear a little bit this is
brood x where it's just like
insane the 17-year cicadas are nuts
and uh we've been feeding to the
chickens chickens love them uh bucko our
cat was just sitting there
like really slowly just mauling once
like taking his time with it you know
and because cats like that when they're
still alive and it's like struggling
so uh yeah i don't know i brought this
one up just to be like as an aside
we got these meat shortages coming and
they're telling people like it's time to
uh to eat the bugs i kind of feel like
a big problem with what's happening is
for one joe biden is doing this
unemployment boost
they're doing the child tax credit so
they're giving people money like crazy
nobody wants to work there are supply
side issues
then at the same time we get these cyber
attacks and that's why i kind of feel
like it's all kind of weird
you know i'll give you some historical
context about the idea of conspiracies
real quick
and then we'll go to the next subject
but when uh the gulf of
the gulf of tonkin incident happened
that's that that that was when the u.s
claimed to have been attacked and so we
were forced to enter the vietnam war
never happened i guess historians now
say it's it's not true
that it was it was a false flag or
there's no evidence to claim that we
were attacked in the gulf of tonkin
and it was likely just made up so that
we would enter the war when that
happened
people had no idea like imagine you're
like sitting in your room
and then all the stuff is happening in
vietnam and you have no idea and then a
week later you find out
or more importantly like imagine the
revolutionary war you're sitting in your
house
you just finished you know farming or
whatever and at that moment they signed
a declaration of independence
400 miles away you have no idea you find
out a month later when a puzzle carrier
shows up you're like oh it went
independent last month i guess all right
so what's happening right now which is
which i find interesting
is that the media wouldn't be telling us
if there was a very serious conflict
happening
something that was targeting our
critical infrastructure they wouldn't be
telling us
if something like right now there could
be a very serious thing that just
happens there could be another cyber
attack
a case in point an insurance company got
hit by a cyber attack by ransomware
before the uh colonial pipeline yeah we
didn't know about it
they never reported it so this kind of
stuff could be happening
we got no idea and what's crazy is the
media will tell you you're a conspiracy
theorist if you if you if you
pontificate on why is it that we have a
meat shortage
why is the people aren't working and
then a meat plant gets hacked
the weird thing to me about it is why
would why would hackers
go after oil and meat production
wouldn't they want to go after i don't
know an insurance company
or banks the grid
electricity oh yeah that'll be the next
electric grid
one though so many people are dependent
on it yeah but they just want a quick
ransom right
it sounds like you're saying it's an act
of war against civilian population
i was just thinking if you went for the
most damage wouldn't that be your
goal if if you so
so the the hacker group came out and
like said like we don't we didn't mean
to affect society this way
so if you're trying to make money to be
a millionaire you don't want to shut
down an oil pipeline you need the gas
too
you want to eat a cheeseburger same as
everybody else you just want to be rich
yeah so why go after
meat and oil instead of like
a financial institution unless there's
something going on that we don't know
about
which is gonna get worse
there's the theory that the govern the
the
the market was crashing anyway and that
they they people were happy to use the
covid lockdown as an excuse to start
printing massive amounts of money and
just expediate the
the crash ultimately so if that was the
case there then we see like a meat
shortage so maybe then now they're
expediating that
by trying to hack it but then that just
leads towards malice i don't know if
it's like a malicious hacker or a
government agent that's doing it to
disrupt like a chinese
thing or if it's just easy targets
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time